>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP,
UNLOADED ON DEMOCRATS AT NORTH
CAROLINE'S NORTH CONDUCT,
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT.
THE PRESIDENT, URGING VOTERS
WHILE ALSO SLAMMING DEMOCRAT'S
PROGRESS OR POLICIES.
HIM HERE.
>> President Trump: A VOTE FOR
ANY DEMOCRAT IN 2020 AND A VOTE
FOR ANY DEMOCRAT TOMORROW IN
NORTH CAROLINA IS A VOTE FOR THE
RISE OF RADICAL SOCIALISM AND
THE DISCRETION            DESTRC
THE DISCRETION            DESTRI
THE DISCRETION            DESTRN
THE DISCRETION            DESTRH
THE DISCRETION            DESTRE
THE DISCRETION            DESTRA
THE DISCRETION            DESTRI
THE DISCRETION            DESTRN
DREAM.
I WOULDN'T MIND FIGHTING THE
DEMOCRATS.
WE REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT IT AS
THE MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS.
IT'S ONE AND THE SAME.
THEY TRIED TO DO THE RECESSION
THING.
YOU KNOW, THEY TRIED THE RUSSIA
THAT DIDN'T WORK.
THEY TRIED MANY OTHER THINGS.
>> Dana: SO, THE PRESIDENT, IN
HIS ELEMENT, WON.
VOTER FRAUD IS AN ISSUE THAT LED
TO THIS SPECIAL ELECTION.
SPECIAL ELECTION, USUALLY LOW
VOTER TURNOUT.
YOU'VE GOT NORTH CAROLINA COMING
THROUGH THE HURRICANE.
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO TRY TO
FLIP THAT LIKE OBAMA DID IN
2008, BUT THE PRESIDENT IS GOING
TO BE THERE ALL THE TIME,
INCLUDING AT THAT CONVENTION.
TO BE FAR WHAT'S INTERESTING TO
ME IS I THINK THE PRESIDENT ONE
IN THIS DISTRICT.
THAT'S A KEY POINT.
SUDDENLY, HE'S THERE.
HE'S THERE WAS SOME ANXIETY.
YOU GET THE BOARD OF ELECTIONS
SAYING WE HAVE TO HAVE A REDO.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING THROUGH
TODAY.
RIGHT NOW, THE POLL SHOW SOME
TIDE.
>> Dana: DEMOCRATS FEEL PRETTY
GOOD ABOUT TYING IT?
>> Juan: THEY DO.
PRETTY YOUNG, ENERGETIC
CANDIDATES.
>> Dana: SMART FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO GO, BECAUSE WHETHER
HE WENT DOWN THERE AND
CAMPAIGNED ORDINATE, NO MATTER
WHAT THE OUTCOME WAS, EVERYONE
WAS GOING TO .2 PRESIDENT TRUMP
FOR THE WIN OR THE LOSS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS ONE OF THE SWING STATES.
THERE ARE A LOT OF DEMOCRATS IN
THIS RACE.
HE WANTS TO BEAT THE BISHOP.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S GOING TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
THEY WILL CONSIDER THAT A
VICTORY.
>> Dana: THEY WILL.
CAN WE PLAY ANOTHER SOUND BITE?
>> Jesse: SURE.
WE DON'T NEED MY PERMISSION.
>> President Trump: I'M NOT A
VAIN PERSON.
I KNOW I HAVE NO VEIN PEOPLE,
ESPECIALLY THESE INCREDIBLE
LADIES IN THE FRONT.
BUT I LOOK BETTER UNDER AN
INCANDESCENT LIGHT THAN THESE
CRAZY LIGHTS THAT ARE BEAMING
DOWN ON ME.
>> Dana: LIGHTING, VERY
CRITICAL.
HE KNOWS THAT.
>> Jesse: I'M NOT A VAIN
PERSON.
THE MEDIA ALREADY FACT-CHECKED
THAT.
FALSE.
WE WERE ALL SAYING, WE ALL
AGREE.
WE LOOK BETTER UNDER
INCANDESCENT LIGHTS.
BUT I GUESS, THEY ARE BAD FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT.
BUT HOW BAD ARE THEY?
>> Dana: YOU KNOW WHAT WE'VE
DONE?
WE DON'T A GREAT JOB OF
INNOVATING SO WE HAVE MORE
EFFICIENT LIGHTING AND IT'S ALSO
MORE INEXPENSIVE, AND WE ALSO
LOOK GOOD.
HE SAYING THE GOVERNMENT IS
TELLING YOU YOU CAN'T HAVE
YOUR OLD LIGHT BULBS.
THEY DON'T LIKE THE IDEA THAT
THE GOVERNMENT IS MANDATING IT,
SO THEY WANT TO KEEP THEIR LIGHT
BULBS.
>> BLACK MARKET, DANA PERINO.
>> Dana: THAT WAS ANNOUNCED IN
2007, WHEN THEY RAISED THE
STANDARD.
EVERY TIME PETER WILL GO TO THE
STORE, I WOULD SAY, BY THE WAY,
PICK UP SOME OF THOSE LIGHT
BULBS, BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW